hello and welcome to this video playing
paranoid and yeah 1 win in two drawers I
got against the sky so let's see we have
them the Dutch and only 92 d7
interesting
and probably his son preparing some c5
with this
Jim to have something probably not yeah
but it did no it isn't perfect as if if
okay all that thought for naught I
thought see five in one go that that
actually was interesting but he didn't
have that on the radio at all it seems
yeah I think I'm taking this and here
yeah this night should go to f4 to d3 to
e5 ultimately but let's see what happens
it seems he is out 45
okay okay i just don't want to give him
all night you for was interesting still
is interesting actually hmm ok Knight f3
knight you for that's the problem if I
cannot play 93 now it's a little bit
it's a little bit irritating aunt is out
for Bishop we aid
I g4 queen bee three I he simply doesn't
pay any attention to that kind of things
I thought Nyjah for queen bee three was
was good but does not relevant he simply
play / should be eight immediately okay
so here you probably have to take so it
doesn't might this yam essentially a
pawn up on the kingside four against
three it's gained a little bit of space
they are cool I can I can do the
minority attack with before but I first
want a little bit of space iam just
pre-emptive before he plays g5 and stuff
okay five maybe g6 takes rook f3m this
is very annoying yeah and this is
spotted immediately shoot badly timed
him very badly timed by me okay now I
cannot take andrew go 3s echinops I
cannot do that so after and play your
father for the spin on the fo
kien external tanks will graph 623
doesn't work okay yeah I can still take
this pawn here right nothing wrong with
that g4 duped you for good for white
should be good from what
okay i can move first ask questions
later and now i can take your g1 check
King somewhere Queen g3 had super
dangerous jab time morning maybe try and
survive it but looks I has King over
here some he's got 20 i have seven okay
it's a bit of a shame
you can take it of course roop 27 check
it's not the drugs and fortunately maybe
there's a draw check check check check
draw a third check check himself of
course check check check check around
yeah it was that wasn't enough from this
position but okay I simply blundered
this rook f3 idea here anti yes sir that
he has this stuff and this I cannot
stand down this is impossible to hold
hmm yeah so I just I should just wait
your phone mode then my position is just
very comfortable I've got three against
two here on the kingside I still have
the minority attack ideas even putting
something like this up it's not bad and
then play on the queenside because in
the end game you can own invade so it's
a bit disappointing and I really was
surprised that and here I mean maybe I
have nothing as possible jan i can go
clean air for yeah i'm just enjoy i was
thinking there should be something here
but it is nothing and this just a draw
check I didn't see it so clearly in Jam
another interesting moment was we're
here I took a long time because i felt
like 94 as a problem ikea but i had
calculated that this
I had at count this calculated that
decide this is good for me go back that
took a bit of time and then as usual he
played like this in a second which is
maybe objectively correct but still
again together said this is a slightly
more comfortable for white at least but
I screw it down later okay anyway this
is a draw at the end thanks for watching